February 18 2023 I finally cracked it
these creatives with their comic books
making movies have zero respect for the
science of Style no matter how realistic
they want their movies to be they don't
consider the realistic consequences of
the actions of their Antics and now I
have proof proof that Batman should be
dead and the reasoning is explosive
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that knows that theorists are
not a superstitious and cowardly Lots
you want to know how I know that friends
just look at the wide array of content
that we've covered over the years we've
exposed Mario's truly Psychopathic
nature played rocket league in real life
with real cars we've predicted the
future of superhero franchises and
analyzed how to survive every single
horror movie imaginable we've cried
while eating spicy foods and we've
worked out the best ways to get the most
bang for your bucket buffets and now
today my friends we're ready for the
next step in our theorizing adventure
today is a huge momentous Day loyal
theorists today we are launching the
First new theorist Channel since 2020
the fourth little quadrant of our logo
is finally getting filled completing
that little Simon Says ring of YouTube
and bringing us one step closer to
theorist world domination ladies and
gentlemen I introduce you to style
Theory yep we have ourselves a whole
Channel That's dedicated to style
Fashion Beauty and hygiene right now
with five brand new theories over there
for you to go and watch right now after
you finish this one now I know what
you're thinking style how are you gonna
theorize about style exactly the same
way that we theorize about film games
and food because everything and anything
that you're passionate about are things
that you can theorize about the same
research science history and lore
analysis that we used to discuss and
decode analog horror superheroes and
Anime 100 apply to the very real world
of clothes makeup hair and hygiene did
you know that your old makeup might be
killing you have you ever wondered about
school uniforms and whether they do
anything good for the students you know
Hulk's purple pants what do you think
those might be made out of and speaking
of fictional clothing have you ever
wondered just how effective skimpy armor
from fantasy movies and video games
would actually be and lastly since we're
talking about movies what about
Cinderella's glass slipper can you make
clothing out of glass or like on the new
Netflix show Wednesday she says she's
allergic to color can you actually be
allergic to color in your clothing all
of that and more is going to be coming
your way over on this new channel so go
check it out after you finish this
episode right now subscribing to style
theory is the single best way that you
can help both us and yourself out not
only are you gonna be getting yourself
some super interesting educational
videos about all sorts of fun topics
that are all very real and applicable to
your everyday life but if we can manage
to get a million subscribers by the end
of the month that'll put style Theory as
one of the top fashion channels on
YouTube so help us help yourself and
let's dominate a whole new portion of
YouTube My Friends the link to style
Theory and its five brand new theories
that just dropped today hear that right
five new videos that are brand new right
now all of that is in the top line of
the description and the I card in the
top right hand corner of the screen so
go click on that over there but make
sure that you're opening it in a new
window because here we still got to talk
about one of the most iconic pieces of
clothing and all of Pop Culture the bat
suit loyal theorists there have been a
lot of bad suits on film over the years
we've had spandex suits rubber masks
military grade spelunking gear comic
accurate capes and cows and even bat
nipples for some reason but I think my
favorite incarnation of the suit so far
has to be the realistic version that we
see in director Matt Reeves is the
Batman see this suit looks like the
stuff that this Bruce Wayne could have
realistically found and cobbled together
himself and it really followed the vibe
that was set by the rest of this version
of the caved Crusader the Batman follows
the tried and tested formula of bat
films that we've seen over the years
Bruce Wayne's parents are killed in
front of him turning him into an
edgelord cosplayer who takes out his
frustrations on the superstitious
cowardly lot that is the criminal
underworld of Gotham City
but this go around things are a lot more
grounded well Christopher Nolan's Batman
was a Suave Globetrotter with unlimited
resources and Zack Snyder's Batman was a
murderous psychopath with an exoskeleton
Mac on the surface level this Batman
seems a lot more realistic he wears
combat boots that he probably picked up
from the local Army Surplus Store he
drives a muscle car Batmobile that he
clearly modified himself he listens to
Nirvana while journaling about his
feelings the film even Embraces the idea
of cycles of violence with Batman being
the inspiration for a lot of the
lunatics that he's trying to stop which
sometimes gets just a wee bit too real
Matt Reeves and the other filmmakers
involved in the Batman clearly put a lot
of time effort and energy into making
this the most practical realistic and
down-to-earth iteration of the character
that we've ever seen on film which is
why it's so weird for me that the
battenson shrugs off bullets with such
alarming regularity at one point even
takes a shotgun blast point blank to the
chest for a smooch and Catwoman dusting
himself off and beating the poop out of
the guy who shot him seriously for as
grounded as this take on the hero might
seem on the outside the Batman has
bullets bouncing off of the bat suit
more than Superman's chest that just
didn't sit right with me our billionaire
suddenly reality Benders now what are
your superpowers again
I'm rich well not exactly is he loyal
theorists even if Batman had the best
body armor in the world his ability of
affluence wouldn't have let him limp
away from the events of this movie and
not for the reasons that you might think
I don't even have to go into that
ridiculous scene where he face plants
into a bridge going like 45 miles an
hour either nope the reason that Batman
would be dead is a lot softer than that
so put on your super suits and Stand
brutingly in the Rain there loyal
theorists let's dive in so let's just
start off by looking at how exactly
bulletproof armor Works see bullets are
deadly because they concentrate an
enormous amount of force onto a small
surface area allowing bullets to tear
through almost anything that they hit
bulletproof armor works by taking the
force of that bullet and then spreading
it out over a larger surface area
preventing it from penetrating your body
and wreaking havoc on your internal
organs don't get me wrong it's still
gonna hurt leaving you winded and
bruised but it makes it substantially
more likely that you'll be able to
survive getting shots we've actually
touched on this subject before in my
game theory discussing whether or not
you should bring a knife to a gunfight
and we found that Bulletproof proof
isn't exactly the right phrase bullet
resistant is more accurate in pop
culture the most commonly cited type of
this sort of bullet resistant armor is
known as Kevlar which actually isn't
what you probably expect it to be when
you hear the word armor the stuff isn't
some sort of metal or anything like that
it's actually a bunch of synthetic
fibers interwoven together which makes
it really good at dispersing the force
of bullets as they strike the Kevlar yep
you're that right Kevlar is technically
a fabric fun fact Kevlar was originally
developed by the DuPont company who were
also the minds behind another superhero
staple spandex we actually talk about
exactly that and a whole lot more in our
episode about Hulk's pants the new
episode over on style Theory so you
should go check it out just another
Shameless plug anyway most of the guns
that are used by Falcone's goons and the
Riddler's henchmen were either pistols
or submachine guns that fire nine
millimeter rounds which Kevlar would do
a pretty good job at stopping but here's
the thing that's talking about firing
from a distance when fired at
point-blank range like we see quite a
bit during the Batman kifler doesn't do
the best job of stopping the bullets
depending on where they hit the armor
some bullets would have a good chance at
breaking through and entering the body
that's not even mentioning that some of
the bad guys use bigger guns with more
powerful bullets especially during the
finale fight above Gotham Square Garden
here we can clearly see Batman getting
hit with bullets fired by M16 and
Winchester rifles which both shoot 556
Nato rounds and remember Kevlar isn't
bulletproof just bullet resistant and
556 rounds fired by those rifles would
absolutely be able to break through it
no problem thankfully for Batman though
Kevlar isn't the strongest type of body
armor out there it's actually considered
a soft body armor which you can clearly
see here in this video by tell Felder
Mouse notice how it basically folds
around the bullets to stop him it almost
looks like it's catching the bullets
right given the fact that we don't see
anything like this happen when Batman
gets shot in the film instead the
bullets just bounce off of him with
Sparks clearly he's wearing some sort of
hard body armor according to the
National Institute of Justice there are
five different categories of body armor
used in modern times these include level
2A level 2 level 3A level 3 and level
four just in case you're wondering level
one body armor does exist it's no longer
considered acceptable by the nij also
those a classifications just get shoved
between existing classes when an armor
doesn't quite fit into one of the
categories the 2A through 3A levels are
all soft armors with Kevlar ranking
somewhere right in the middle there it
means that Kevlar is actually on the
weaker side of modern body armor believe
it or not that might come as a surprise
to you if you've ever heard that Kevlar
is stronger than steel and yeah I mean
that's still true that just doesn't
paint you a complete picture Kevlar is
indeed up to five times stronger than
steel if you compare their strength to
weight ratio basically steel armor that
weighs the same as a Kevlar vest won't
be offering that much protection but
that doesn't mean that steel can't stop
bullets if you're willing to wear a full
suit of armor out into the field the
YouTube channel Demolition Ranch
actually did a test to show just how
effective steel armor can be at stopping
bullets
stop there that was a good one but steel
isn't even the best option for plate
armor nowadays we are long past the
Middle Ages after all and Batman has
himself the entire r d Department of
Wayne Enterprises at his fingertips
these days the highest nij rated armor
consists of several solid plates usually
made from some sort of ceramic composite
something that is literally harder than
the bullets that are being fired at it
according to the nij the strongest level
4 armor is able to withstand
armor-piercing rounds quote obtained
from U.S military M2 AP ammunition if
none of that means anything to you which
why would it we are talking about some
seriously heavy Firepower this stuff can
penetrate three-quarter inches of Steel
with no issue those ceramic plates are
going to be able to stop the weaker nine
millimeter and 556 ammo shot by most of
Riddlers and falcony's goons no problem
honestly these plates aren't even that
expensive by Batman standards I was able
to find commercially available military
grade nine and a half inch by 12 and a
half inch level 4 armor plating for just
around 600 per plate and given Bruce
Wayne's resources it's even feasible
that the parts of the bat suit that
needed to be flexible and aren't armor
plated could be made from Kevlar so this
super suit of armor might actually be
legit it would also probably be able to
stop that point-blank shotgun blast that
briefly winded Batman during the finale
fight YouTuber Paul Harrell tested
common shotgun pellet projectiles
against level 3A soft body armor which
is weaker than the ceramic plates and
things went really well despite multiple
direct hits
now remember this vest has already been
shot with nine pellets so it was
compromised before we ever taped it to
this log but it got hit with the second
nine pellets and stopped every one of
them even when testing much heavier slug
projectiles the heavily compromised
level 3A vest was able to stop the
bullet even though a great deal of
concussive force was able to get through
that Forest would have been lessened had
this been level 4 armor like Batman's
wearing probably saving his life even if
he got knocked to his butt which
perfectly lines up with what we see in
the movie Batman gets hit by the shotgun
and though the armor stops the
projectile he flies backwards from the
concussive force so is that it the
Batman's armor is legit does all of this
prove that Bruce Wayne could have put on
this bat suit and had all those cool
fight scenes and dark hallways and come
out on the other end with only a few
bruises to show for it all well not
exactly loyal theorists because bullets
bouncing off his armor isn't the only
life-threatening situation that Bruce
Wayne finds himself in in the Batman
during one of the most tense scenes in
the film The Riddler straps an explosive
collar onto the District Attorney's neck
in an attempt to get him to confess
who's at the root of the government's
corruption Batman both trying to save
the DA's life and get himself the same
information stands real close so he can
do the whole grab whisper shtick instead
of just talking like a normal person of
course because we're only about halfway
through the movie at this point we can't
solve the mystery yet the D.A refuses to
give a name and the bomb goes off
throwing Batman across the room and
knocking him unconscious yeah no this
absolutely stretches the edge of
believability in a lot of ways but the
most obvious one given that we just
deduced that the bat suit is level four
plated armor this scene and the
explosion would have a hundred percent
killed Batman see explosive Ordnance
disposal suits or just bomb suits for
short or very complicated pieces of
clothing up until the mid-1990s they
were actually made of Kevlar with armor
plating all in an effort to stop
shrapnel from killing the bomb
technicians but that type of armor
didn't provide protection against the
blast waves in the unfortunate situation
where an explosive actually went off
they produced shock waves that ripped
through the bodies of the people that
were trying to defuse them so even if
there was no injury from shrapnel the
lungs and other internal organs of the
person would be wounded oftentimes these
wounds were fatal this was actually such
a huge deal at the time and happened so
frequently that the these sorts of
injuries earned themselves the nickname
blast lung researchers found that Kevlar
and armor plating by themselves just
couldn't offer enough protection but
when they were layered with both a high
and low density acoustic foam suddenly
the people in the suits were far more
likely to survive the blast waves so
because of this modern bomb suits are
made not only from Kevlar and Ballistic
plating like we see with Batman's suit
but also several layers of both high and
low density protective foam that's
partially what gives the bomb suit that
iconic bulky look which the Batman lacks
with its thinner sleeker silhouette and
all of this is without even mentioning
the bomb suit helmets which have
themselves giant thick visors made from
fully laminated acrylic and
polycarbonate to protect from shrapnel
entering the face in short there's just
no way that the bat suit in the movie
has the protective layering required to
survive a point-blank explosion
especially when battenson's lower face
is completely uncovered in fact now that
I'm thinking about it even with this
super strong basically bulletproof suit
of armor who would think that Bruce
Wayne would be smart enough to cover his
entire face if he's expecting to be shot
at all the time between that and
approaching an active armed bomb without
any sort of bomb suit yeah I'd say that
this Bruce Wayne has himself an active
Death Wish forget the Batman Robert
Pattinson is more accurately described
as the dead man but hey that's just a
theory a film Theory and you know what
other superhero has himself an
unrealistic costume that stretches the
bounds of reality The Incredible Hulk
and his purple pants if you want to know
why exactly these things stay on the
Hulk while all his shirts rip off his
body or why this single pair of pants
probably costs more than a luxury
Lamborghini you should probably go check
out the brand new channel style theory
link is on screen right now and that's
not all loyal theorists in addition to
that Hulk episode there are four other
new episodes over there today that is
five entirely new theories covering
everything from how your makeup might be
poisoning you the conspiracy behind
women's Pockets whether math can make
someone's face more beautiful and
whether or not you can literally kill
someone with your clothes please go on
over there and subscribe to style Theory
so we can hit a million subscribers by
the end of the month it's absolutely
free your help would be wonderful and
much appreciated to all of us over here
who've been working really hard on this
channel and if we can manage to hit a
million subscribers by the end of the
month oh that would be amazing thank you
so much for supporting the theorist
efforts over the years and thank you for
letting us get to this next major
milestone in our journey I love you guys
and I'll see you on this channel next
week